one of the big things you say all the
time rich is Chase Excellence uh not
women
and and I've kind of rephrased that to
uh that movie Field of Dreams if you
build it they will come right where it's
more important for men to work on
themselves to chase your own success
Chase your own dreams build your own
kingdom
and then once you have that they will
come out of the woodwork and you will
have your choice of women is that is
that true
yeah I always tell guys the chase
excellence and never chase women because
you will find
when you're doing something of some
significance then women will be
attracted to you they're like the moons
of Endor if you want to call it whatever
they sort of just start orbiting around
you they'll start following you on on
social media they're still they'll start
to comment on your uh social influencer
posts your videos whatever you happen to
do and um that's just what they do you
know women look for strong virtuous uh
you know men that are essentially
um how can I put this you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to cut this part
out no man
um
Unbreakable unshakable
uh competent I think is a word that yes
I would use there is you know women like
competent men right men that can get
done that can make it rain that can
solve problems that don't need to call
the plumber to fix something basic in a
dishwasher you know guys like that
gotcha Now Rich you you got into a
little bit of dating app and dating app
profiles now I have a buddy 40 years old
a little younger to me tall dude good
looking dude he's on dating apps and he
was over the house the other night and
I'm like so brother how's everything
working out and he's like dude this is
the land of broken toys
um why are all these broken women on
dating apps
I think it's just women that's that's
just the state of women today I don't
think that dating acts apps particularly
attract broken women it's just it gives
them a place to amplify their presence
and then you find them there you also
have to keep in mind too that you know
women that are of better higher
character
um usually don't need to use dating apps
probably because they're either linked
up with a guy might be married might be
in a relationship
um
you don't get let's just say that the
pickings aren't the greatest on dating
apps they're kind of more so like
leftover women you don't get a lot of
tens on there if you know what I'm
saying exactly um what are the things
that you probably notice I'm a little
famous for on Twitter is
um I get a lot of stuff sent to me um
you know screenshots of dating profiles
and you'll be astonished at the number
that show up in my feed of pregnant
women that are in their 20s with four
kids already from four different fathers
saying that they want to get right uh
you know with a man and settle down and
have them become the father that steps
up and raise the kids that aren't there
sort of thing it's it's out there
um and these are the ones that obviously
get you know the most attention because
they're most uh you know Sensational
they're the ones that get pushed out
there on social media because it's like
oh look at this entitled woman who
thinks that she's deserve it of a high
class high quality you know the guy with
the six six is six foot tall is six pack
abs six figure income all that stuff
like and the 600 horsepower car the 600
yeah so there's a little bit of delusion
there when it comes to women on on
dating absent why wouldn't they be
delusional you know women have women
have been put up on a pedestal their
entire lives by men and they don't they
don't rationalize in their head they
don't actually compute that their value
has declined as they've gotten older as
they've had children as they've had
children with multiple men as they show
up on dating apps already pregnant with
another man's seed in their belly you
know it it doesn't compute they still
think that they're that 18 year old
hottie that went down to Cancun that
everybody you know was talking to or in
high school like they don't adjust
themselves they don't sort of uh
um you know re recalibrate themselves to
the reality of the world so that's just
something that you have to contend with
as a guy is women have that entitlement
sort of Personality mindset today
because all they have to do I mean an
average five Teddy can go on a Instagram
and post an average picture of herself
and hundreds of guys thousands of guys
might even come in swoop in betas you
know beta orbiters thirsty guys that
don't have a lot of attention with women
we live in a simp economy today this is
why things like only fans is so popular
you have so many of these losers out
there giving away their hard-earned
money to very average women for things
like you know a message back or even
more disgusting I mean there's been
these women that have that have sold uh
used underwear during bath water bath
water Sanitary products they've sold to
some of these thirsty betas that follow
them so this is a world that we live in
I mean we live in a simp economy today
there's a lot of guys that are at that
spot unfortunately well and a lot of
these guys too
on their dating apps and again my buddy
brother we sat down we took a look at
all this stuff on these dating apps and
I actually showed him in the book how to
fix his profile okay and because you do
touch on that
and he uh all these women are like I
want an alpha man but then you see these
guys on there saying I'm an alpha I'm
this I'm that and I told him I said he
goes should I put something like that in
my profile I said first off brother
don't get your feelings hurt you're not
an alpha okay you can get there but
you're not there second off true Alphas
don't have to go out and announce that
they are alphas I said you're free to
say that yes you take any group of
people rich I was I was law enforcement
I was in the military I played uh
division one Collegiate Athletics
you can sit back and look at a group of
people and realize who the leader of
that group is without any titles without
any ranks without anything you can
observe Behavior
and see who the alpha is and I told him
I said listen you never call yourself an
alpha I said that's a term that other
men and women will call you
true Alphas don't go I'm the alpha that
just doesn't happen yeah the king
doesn't need to announce that he's the
king he's just known as the King right
exactly exactly if you have to let
people know you're in charge you're
really not in charge
and then Rich on these dating apps too
these women in their profiles
my kids come first and I know you got a
lot to say about that so go ahead have
at it brother yeah good you know have
fun with your kids being first because
I'm not coming second third fourth fifth
after the cat your job and whatever else
is going on in your world drinking wine
with your girlfriends
um you'll get that and look women I mean
if you're willing to listen and observe
the facts and accept them for what they
are they will tell you what they're
about right you know how many times have
you seen on dating apps uh oh I'm a mom
to three superhumans or whatever and
it's like really your kids are solving
cold fusion like like what is little
Johnny doing today right he's playing
video games and eating fruit loops that
you can't cook so it like you know it's
it's a sales pitch right like everything
on dating apps is going to be marketing
and women will try to Market themselves
and the position you know they're trying
to sell is I'm a good mom I'm a good
person you know I'm the kind of person
that you want to be around sort of thing
interestingly though they don't want
much to do with your kids they don't
want to have uh any responsibility your
kids if you have kids but they will want
authority over them but they won't allow
you to have any kind of authority over
their kids if you get into a long-term
relationship but you will have to have
some responsibility to raising those
kids as if they're your own so it's not
a great deal I mean not all women will
be like that but you will find a large
proportion of women on The Dating
Marketplace that will put their kids
first their jobs second you know their
three cats fourth and their Night Out
salsa dancing and drinking with their
girlfriend's Fifth and you're going to
show up six you know sort of thing and
these guys are happy to do that because
it's low hanging fruit and for some of
them it's just the best they can get
right so yeah there's always going to be
a contingent of the population the male
population that will fall for that and
and the single mom issue rich and I I I
read about the situation that you had
getting involved with a single mom and
and it was almost identical to a
situation that I had in the past to
where
you had to provide you were the provider
uh the father in this case was just out
of the picture non-existent the other
side of the country
but don't dare discipline
don't dare
tell Johnny or Joey hey knock it off sit
down
but you can put the roof over the head
food on the table close on the back
rides to school rides to this go do this
go do that pay for pay for everything at
the zoo but
don't tell Johnny or Joey to behave
yeah that's the whole You've got
responsibility to those kids but no
authority over them and when you have
responsibilities with no Authority
that's essentially slavery why would you
sign up for that it's a bad deal it is
it is and guys if you're listening you
need to be listening okay Rich lays
everything out and it was it was years
and years and years everything that I've
been looking at put together
like beautifully Rich beautifully and
you know we always used to have a joke
you know me and my buddies hey be the
guy hey women want me and men want to be
me correct and that's not a joke that's
a real thing
correct 100 yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out